my brother tells me to keep your mouth shut
unusual talent for sell sword he tells me you
[__] gold just like your father this place safe
there's this knight lay good got thunderbolts on
his shield no right here is where I [__]
his wife she's a screamer that one if they
don't hear her they won't hear it off I still
have my right charge when I'm growing it back
[Music]
that was me knocking your ass to the dirt
with your own hand you learn to fight like
a good little boy I bet that thrust through
the mad Kings back was pretty as a picture
you want to fight pretty or you want to
win you talk to my brother this way oh
it's time you got used to it who's that Jimmy
[__] molester the Dornish are crazy all they
want to do is to fight and [__] [__] and
fight this should be happy to go back there
there's nothing like a good fight
to get you in the mood for [__]
and there's nothing like a [__] man
Dornish girl tickler your head for the
next fight it's how the two work together
now we're gonna be doing a lot of fighting
on sure well I am but I don't imagine
we'll get to stick around for the rest
what's shift where would you choose in my
own keep don't give my online watching the
son's grovel for a fortune how disappointing
I've thought you'd have something moisturizing
plant I've had an exciting life I want my
death to be boring how do you want to go
how many account for how many do you think
you can take one give you slow [__] in the
ass nice move look you had a wonderful teacher
first we need to bury these bodies do you know
how long it will take us to dig all those old
I can't dig very well with one hand not at all
in a voice that was sweet as alright I'm
coming to the best part trying to blend in
don't want a boy don't hear eysan once we've
got the princess then what I like to improvise
that explains the golden hand well she's made
herself at home Prince trystane here is a man
of mercy he's agreed to grant you your freedom
I'm glad to hear it there was one condition
someone needs to teach so sad [__] how to
dig trenches someone certainly does oh no not
me I'm just an op don't sell sword you're an
annoyance of nice that's quite a difference I
nice don't get paid you have better instincts
than any office and the Lannister army that's
like saying I have a bigger [__] than anyone
in the unsullied army you promised me a lordship
and a castle and a highborn beauty for the
wife and you'll get all three a Lannister
all gone say don't [__] say that words of the
blackfish I want to Pali Pali or a fight he's an
old man you've got one hand my money's on the
old boy you don't even have to do anything do
you you just sit there her rich slab of beef
from all the birds compacted your welcome to
her she doesn't want me she wants your golden
fingers up like 20 those who have their eyes on
you and their eyes when you [__] of my type
not blonde enough Queen of thorns give you one
last prick in the balls before saying goodbye
save my confessions for the High Septon there
is still a question of my price that's a lot of
money I just gave it's not a castle more you own
the more weighs you down oh is that why you're
so [__] gone Hey Oh your new rich is weighing
you down the run of the Blackwater formerly of
whatever nameless [__] heap you're from with
a saddlebag full of gold complaining about
not getting paid so Jamie Rick on dick on I
didn't expect it to smell like that
then [__] themselves when they die
then the teacher that at fancy lad
school well learnt it when I was five
listen to me Conti till I get what I'm owed a
dragon doesn't get to kill you you don't get
to kill you only I get to kill you you're
[__] don't you mean we're [__] no I do
not dragons are where our partnership ends
I'm not gonna be around when those things
start spitting fire on Kings landed and without
[__] you wouldn't find me fighting in an army
if I had no Cochran what's left to fight
for doled I spend my life around soldiers
what do you think they spend that gold on
family not without the [__] you don't